pas parler la famille et d'alain de la
famille delon et la famille al anon ce
qu'on va faire une nouvelle affaire à
l'idée comme on dit c'est incroyable ce
qui se passe c'est d'ailleurs dans un
instant doha mary sue briller boulogne
ânesse d'alain delon qui décide qui
désirent lancer un appel
vous allez voir il sera en direct avec
nous dans un instant mais on va évoquer
donc cette famille on va revenir sur le
conflit qui lie à dans la famille de nom
parce qu'il ya encore eu des
rebondissements
aujourd'hui et c'était le 18 avril en
avril dernier dans l'ordre des pros sur
ses news alain delon avait enfoncé sa
fille anouchka juste après il faisait
moins de compliments à son fils alain
fabien et déjà ça avait démarré comme ça
regarde votre jeune garçon à un enviable
oui allez cette phrase ville a dit mon
père m'a toujours dit qu'il faut de la
race des seigneurs et est ce que vous
vous retrouvez quand même 7 justement
cette race des seigneurs en lui chez vos
enfants également tous j'imagine le
phénix sont difficiles je retrouve plus
ses traits et saignant chez ma fille
comme elle s'est exprimée avant lui
c'est par période hachée par moments
c'est par instinct tard pulsions sépare
aussi événement dans la vie c'est
beaucoup de choses à la fois
mais les mon fils alors bernard montiel
on va revenir sur la faire vous allez
expliquer aux téléspectateurs ce qui se
passe autour d'alain delon semences qui
s'est complètement fou
c'est tout un feuilleton et je vous le
dis il ya marie soubrier boulogne qui
nous a rejoint d'être la nièce d'alain
delon vous avez donc un appel à lancer
soir et nous raconter tout ça mais
bernard qui nous a rejoint qu'est ce qui
se passe pour nos téléspectateurs c'est
vrai que ça intéresse tout le monde est
aujourd'hui ton n'a parlé que de ça bon
c'est que l'acteur magnifique qu'est
alain delon et les 83 ans il a eu deux
accidents cardiovasculaires et
cérébrales
c'est très grave il se remet tout
doucement comme l'a dit à l'ats me fait
bien
comme l'a dit anthony son fils et des
offices cris anthony c'est le fils de
nathalie il a eu comme seule femme qu'il
a épousée à dire c'est nathalie delon
voilà la maman d'anthony et anthony
évidemment est un peu agacé tout ce qui
se dit un peu à tord et à travers il est
allé voir son père il ya 15 jours il n'a
pas posté deux photos avec lui n'a pas
voulu le faire parce qu'il préfère qu'on
garde une certaine image de son père
mais attendez alain delon se remet tout
doucement tout va bien on n a rien à
voir avec la faire à l'idée et
heureusement en revanche alain fabien a
posté le week-end dernier il est allé
voir son père en suisse il a posté une
photo avec son papa lé là voici
et ça n'a pas plu à tout le monde
évidemment parce que on n'a pas trop
envie de montrer à l'inde comme ça un
peu fatigué quoi envoyer mais allah est
un battant il va s'en remettre et
anouchka elle le voit son père tous les
jours puisqu'elle vit en suisse mais
parce qu'il ya une histoire de fou alain
delon il est bien là voilà un vivant il
va très bien là et les histoires de foot
déjà autour de l'héritage c'est ça alors
incroyable enfants par les dents parce
que le mois suivant donc après avoir
parlé de sa fille et de alain fabien il
a parlé de son fils anthony il évoque
ses rapports avec lui dit la famille de
longvic un peu sans moi maintenant
anthony a désormais 55 ans est pas tout
à fait un gamin il m'a donné deux
petites filles que j'adore dont l'une a
23 ans et va bientôt me faire
arrière-grand-père suite à cet entretien
anthony delon a réagi en vidéo sur son
compte instagram il a tenu à mettre les
choses au clair et a critiqué le fait
que lui et alain fabien donc son demi
frère ne seront pas à cannes lors de
l'hommage qui avaient été rendus à leur
père regarde
petite mise au point sympathique mais
obligatoire au vu d'un journaliste loi
qui va sortir demain et surtout pour
éviter que ma fille ne soit emmerder
dans les jours qui viennent alors
premièrement nous on papa je n'ai pas 55
en mai 54 première chose deuxième chose
ma fille lou n'est pas enceinte
voilà vous le dis tous bien ma fille lou
n'est pas enceinte
et toi le premier donc tu ne vas pas
être à un grand père et moi dieu merci
pas grand père tout de suite hein
voilà j'ai aussi dit dans cet article
que peut-être qu alain fabien et moi ne
sont une eau à cannes et ben écoute on
sera à cannes
si tu nous invites merci alors donc ils
ont toujours eu des rapports difficiles
en fait de communication parce
qu'anthony ressemble beaucoup à son père
c'est le même si le filet on vous
raconte cette histoire soit parce que ce
qui a mis le feu aux poudres
c'est le 16 mai alain delon révèle que
sa fille sera l'exécutrice testamentaire
dans un entretien accordé à gala alain
delon avait révélé qu'il avait anticipé
son décès en choisissant sa fille voilà
c'est ma fille qui sera l'exécutrice
testamentaire elle aussi mais ce n est
pas l aime pas trop qu'on en parle ce
sera elle et personne d'autre
non seulement à la ma confiance mon
amour mais sait ce qu'elle veut et ce
qu'elle fait à 28 ans et bien voilà il
souhaite éviter comme me l'a dit un
conflit comme c'est le cas pour les à
l'idée nom veut dire je fais tout ça
parce que ça n'arrive pas pour porte pas
que ça arrive je ne voudrais pas que mes
enfants se déchire comme les à l'idée je
prépare tous pensent moment tout sera
réglé avant ma mort que ça plaise ou pas
si je ne le faisais pas ce serait un
déchirement une guerre entre eux j'en
suis sûr dans un stand aura des
révélations folle de mary sue briller
boulogne qui veut faire un appel qui
veut lancer un appel mais c'est vrai que
ça c'est ça qui me voudra oui oui bien
sûr évidemment évidemment évidemment le
alain delon était très blessée parce
qu'il adorait johnny ce qu'elle sait
très bien aussi évidemment par toutes
ces histoires autour de johnny hallyday
comme nous sommes tous blessés par ces
histoires d'héritage du johnny quoi il a
peur que ça entache sa carrière sa vie
et tout le reste
donc il a évité tout ça il a fait tout
récemment c'est très clair c'est déposé
et il a eu le courage de le dire ça
allait toujours eu le courage de dire
les choses en face
donc il a dit vous cassez pas la tête
après ma mort le plus lointain possible
évidemment le plus le plus tard possible
il y aura pas d'histoire c'est louche
cas parce qu'il a eu toujours confiance
en eux jusqu à l été et l etat car c'est
la seule chose il avait reçu une palme
d'or d'honneur dévoile à sa fille
exactement et les deux autres enfants
oui et pas on peut comprendre tient
souvent dit que tu étais très fier de ta
carrière et ya de quoi mais aujourd'hui
c'est moi qui suis fier fier de l'acteur
mais surtout fière de toi et c'est avec
une immense fierté que nous transmettons
la palme d'or d'honneur
alors donc il avait évoqué sa mort lors
de son discours alain delon qu'on va
voir
pourquoi y est qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qu'ils disent les deux garçons
en ce moment là quand ils voient ça a
sûrement moins je sais pas mais sûrement
ils ont été vexés serais tu es jolie
s'il y avait toute la famille je trouve
qu'il y avait eu anthony alain fabien et
anouchka parce qu'ils s'entendent bien
entre eux quand même un bon allié des
petits tiraillements ce moment
évidemment mais ils s'entendent très
bien tous ya pas de problème c'est
dommage je le redis invité les deux
garçons évidemment je comprends qu'il
soit blessé et en plus ils apprennent
entre temps que c'est que ça que ma
petite soeur anouchka qui va gérer la 25
ans qui va gérer le testament c'est sûr
que c'est difficile pour des enfants
christophe c'est pas un autre cas qui
décide d'aller seul annoncé alain delon
c'est sûr donc voilà sur et le rapport
que delon a avec ses fils n'est
évidemment pas le même avec ses filles
puisqu'il ya un rapport forcément
conflictuelles et concurrentielle entre
les deux garçons et la fille qui elle
n'est pas du tout sur le même créneau à
la fabien et l'assureur en bouquins
voilà la voir on voit à quel point leur
son approche de la famille ou qui que le
climat entre à nous jeter ses frères est
absolument glacial et ne communique
quasiment pas alors on va revoir le 10
sport d'alain delon regarde pour moi
plus qu'une fin de carrière je pense que
fin de vie
ce soir c'est un peu un hommage posthume
mais de mon vivant ci est très difficile
c'est de durer et j'ai dur et j'ai duré
62 ans et maintenant je sais que ce qui
est difficile c'est partir lorsque je
vais partir
c'est vrai que bon là c'est c'est un
discours qui était assez poignant et ce
soir on a avec nos maris soubrier
boulogne merci d'être avec nous est la
nièce d'alain delon vous êtes contents
d'être là vallée très timide marine
merci en tout cas d'être avec nous vous
désirez lancé un appel parce que on va
rappeler toute l'histoire vous êtes la
fille de la soeur d'un dôme oui jacques
la seule à être en relation avec un
certain harry boulogne et ari boulogne
alors on va vous expliquer qu'ils
arrivent donnent
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire qu'ils
y arrivent donc à raymond cousin été
élevé par ma grand-mère est adoptée par
mon grand-père mais parce que lui il
explique qu'il ait cherché à être
reconnu par alain delon son succès il
dit que c'est le fils d'alain delon
voilà et qu'il n'a jamais été
officiellement reconnu par alain daumas
à l'aréna jamais ca ca est reconnu par
alain delon
il ya une vidéo en 2001 sur le plateau
de thierry ardisson voilà il le dit il
le dit non mais le disais souvent les
influences d'autrui qui font que harry
demande sa méhari na na na jamais
a toujours été dans un lien d'amour et a
fait avec et n'a jamais eu besoin de
faire enfin c'est bien c'est bien le
sait bien mais c'est je suis sérieuse
assez bien son fils à lundi oui bah oui
mais pas fait ce sont six mais il n'a
marre il n'a pas besoin de cette
reconnaissance paternelle
et justement si je suis là ce soir si je
peux me permettre de continuer bien sûr
alors on va voir la vidéo pour voir
qu'il s'agit regard des pères ben c'est
un père qui ne vous a pas désigné pour
fils puisque alain delon a toujours
refusé de reconnaître cette paternité
pourquoi il l'a jamais fait à votre avis
parce que il s'est nullement rendu amer
a été déboutée ça devait être en 163 je
pense après ma naissance et il n'est pas
que tu aies adn à cette époque là et
depuis
j'ai entamé une procédure de
reconnaissance encore de 18 ans qui a
été zappé couet voilà alors la dresser
des chiens s'étire ardisson en 2001 à
l'âge de 4 ans harry explique que la
mère d'alain delon a tout fait pour le
retrouver parce que c'est elle qui lors
qu'il a élevé un jour un espion envoyé
par là par la famille boulogne donc la
famille d'alain delon on vous voit la
factory finir des verts a appelé en fin
de soirée tout petit que là je vous
aviez déjà fait entre 4 et 5 en voilà
une finition des verres il avaler des
pilules qui était dans le sac de sa mère
d'ailleurs à 90,9 une hépatite et la
mère d'alain delon donc edith boulogne
est venu vous récupérez à new york c'est
cela et vous à embarquer dans ce
pavillon à bourg la reine
elle édite boulogne la mère d'alain
delon est persuadé vous êtes le fils de
son fils tout à fait à la dilution
dizaine est là dit elle a écrit elle a
écrit vous reproduisez une lettre dans
bouka alors c'était pour replacer un
petit peu contexte qu'on revoie harry ce
soit vous avez un appel à faire on son
look est quel est cet appel
harry est en ce moment un jour n ya pas
ce qu'il est sous l'influencé de
quelqu'un et qu'il qui le manipuler
et depuis il a donc assigné à
l'injustice le signal en voilà pour
demander la reconnaissance mais harry
n'a jamais réellement voulu faire cela
parce que même si on est une famille
d'écorché vif on est de famille d'amour
donc ce genre de choses on ne le fait
pas
harry ne l'aurais jamais fait donc là il
le fait parce que quelqu'un lui demande
de faire cela et si je suis là ce soir
c'est incroyable c'est uniquement pour
lui demander de me répondre au téléphone
et d'arrêter cette assignation
car je trouve cela dommage parce que je
trouve cela dommage parce que on aurait
pu arriver à on était en train de
négocier des choses entre nous et on
n'était pas obligé d'en arriver là
voilà de quoi vous n'avez plus nouvelle
c'était il ya quinze jours je crois
cette assignation
oui et en fait depuis 3 mois non carrier
et un drogué par quelqu'un qui kills qui
le manipulent et qui qu'il influence
pour une influence sur cet héritage pour
pourra simplement pourquoi est ce qu il
veut il veut donc faire partie de
l'héritage de sa maman est décédée un
maman de harry c'est une chanteuse ça
pénicaud underground cogner vous étiez
au courant de cette affaire bernard oui
oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr mai
dernier et de l'assignation vous ne
saviez pas du tout elle a bien sûr c'est
vraiment pas du tout c'est incroyable et
donc parce que il faut rappeler un truc
c'est qu'alain delon est bien vivant et
c'est vrai que moi je vois tout ça je
vois tous les gens qui s'agitent autour
et qui disent voilà qui parle déjà
d'héritage et franchement les enfants
anouchka anthony alain-fabien ne parle
pas c'est vrai non vraiment là ils sont
autour de leurs pairs et n'ont qu'une
envie c'est qu'ils vivent le plus
longtemps possible et il pense pas du
tout à l'héritage aucun des trois quoi
franche absolument n'avait filtré
cependant je ne sais pas du tout à se
déchirer les vivants et il va de mieux
en mieux et la 83e mais alors vous vous
êtes très proche de nous le cas chez ses
proches dans notre cas et justement je
viens pour prendre sa défense aussi
parce que je trouve qu'elle est tout le
temps elle sait pas que ça à [ __ ] mais
non mais je trouve qu'on est tout le
temps en train de vie à le jeter tout
sur le dos alors comme alain lui a donné
le droit de s'occuper de cet héritage
forcément bas on a l'impression que con
que c'est une faveur mais c'est pas du
tout une faveur c'est limite une grosse
complications pour sa vie améliorée
savons il a demandé à la demande et à
12,4 qui respecte ce qui l'a décidé
oui tu tries alors qu'est ce qui sera
fait par la suite c'est la volonté
d'allah akbar alors lorsqu'il déclare
que yari ça a été le début d'une
brouille de 17 ont avec son fils alain
delon qu'elle s'est embrouillé avec un
an et on a retrouvé des images
d'archivés très très forte
regarde moi sur parole
c'est vrai je croyais vraiment que mon
fils l'accepterai vraiment au jeu quand
il a su que j'avais le mée b
il m'avait téléphoné par son imprésario
qu'il avait à ce moment là que j'avais
le choix entre le bébé et mon fils mais
c'est la vie il faut vivre avec son
chagrin ma chérie
et c'est pas facile il arrive que le
moment je ne le souhaite pas mais il ya
des moments le désespoir parce que mon
mari est décédé
ça fait 17 ans que j'avais pas vu mon
fils parce qu'il y avait un lit
[Musique]
alors c'est s'échiner cas vous êtes fier
et ému en voyant ces images nous a
quittés élite à l'âge de 84 ans et c'est
vrai que c'est une famille d'écorché vif
on voit là on a l'impression qu'il ya
une malédiction sur cette famille alors
que mine de rien dit tout va bien mine
de rien c'est vrai voilà mais voilà
entre les les enfants entre entre les
tout tout les doutes les voilà toutes
les pistes tout voilà à chaillevois
entre eux mêmes pères et les fils entre
les enfants de familles des problèmes
d'ego si alain delon c'est quand même
une énorme star un super acteur des
films merveilleux
les négos surdimensionné il faut le dire
et c'est normal avec la carrière qu'il a
et c dites vous dit marie vous dit
qu'alain delon un double visage
non mais très long il dit il n'aime pas
les garçons c'est pour ça qu'il était
très dur avec ses fils non parce que
c'est vrai que alain et ma mère se
ressemblent beaucoup et je vois tout ce
que me fait vivre ma mère parce que je
suis une fille et donc je comprends ce
que vivent les garçons de l'autre côté
et ça malheureusement n'y est pour rien
il faut faire avec
et quand vous dites que c'était le choix
d'alain sûrement qu'il n'y ait que
anouchka au festival de cannes je pense
que oui c'est lui qui décide les choses
par moments et perses comme ma mère
décide des choses et on n'a pas de mot à
dire c'est des gens très ferme très têtu
très dur qui veulent qu'on soit des gens
très fort et très dur et donc c'est en
ça qu'ils agissent au site cette façon
là mais quelles sont les relations entre
autres les membres de la famille vous
dit quand on possède ce don il n'y a pas
de famille elle est éclatée écrasé par
la notoriété d'alain delon c'est ce que
vient de dire un peu banal mais en fait
c'est une famille qui est rempli d'amour
mais qui est qui et qui est écorchée par
le décalage des places qui s'est causé à
force d année une à dire que harry n'est
pas le fils d'alain mes deux frères
légalement donc c'est difficile d'avoir
le même rapport entre un frère et un
père on est d'accord et on est tous des
cas les petit à petit donc j'ai un doute
avant que paris ne soit sous emprise
est-ce qu'ils avaient des relations avec
non pas son papa mais avec ses frères et
soeurs n'ont aucune en maintenant une
lance fin il n'en souhaite pas quand il
il a sa petite ville est plus dans le
monde du velvet underground il épate les
marginal un tout image
ben oui les affranchir because amer vous
avez tenté de les rabibocher par le
biais d'anouchka anosy qu'elle avait des
rapports accary ou pas du tout non mais
j'aurais bien aimé je pense que ça
aurait pu très bien fonctionné parce que
la douche qui est une très très belle
personne et si je suis là ce soir c'est
surtout pour la défendre
c'est pour elle que je suis là parce que
je je je je veux pas qu'elle pense que
comme c'est moi qui gère les papiers
daric cette assignation j'étais pas au
courant je pensais pas qu'il allait se
faire influencer je françois villon mais
pas si on méritait elle inquiète pour la
santé de 13 à 16 ans qui n'avait pas de
nouvelles de l'esj n'est pas nouvelle et
je sais que non depuis plus il me répond
pas au téléphone on le hall 1 toxiques
comment savez-vous qu'il a signés alors
son père enfin sauf prétendu peur ce
n'est pas parce que j'ai je
un soir il m'a appelé on m'insulte ans
et en me disant tiens voilà ce que je
viens de faire donc sur le coup j'ai pas
vraiment porté attention qu'on sent que
c'était une délibération soir et
finalement j'ai appris que c'était vrai
et là ça a été je suis tombé par terre
mais à alain delon n'a jamais eu aucune
relation avec lui non aucune
il le voit comme son frère ils sont
frères pour la loi est ce l'état civil
les a donnés c'est mon grand père qui a
adopté harris est pas ma grand mère fils
elle ne pouvait pas oui donc
donc voilà il n'a jamais reconnu fin
août pour lui c'est pas son fils non
pour lui c'est pas son fils n'ont
maintenant même s'il a sa gueule non
c'est pas son fils moi puisque tout le
monde dit c'est vrai on n'a pas de
boulot c'est un retour à huy c'est les
mêmes
c'est même tout à fait les mêmes et dans
tour c'est à dire que il que alain delon
dit que pour lui harry a volé la place
de fils auprès de sa mère donc c'est
pour ça aussi
alors justement vous voulez en venir
donc je redis à venir en fait alain 11 à
ma grand mère parce qu'ils pensent que
sa mère ah oui à magrin à sa mère parce
qu'il est persuadé que c'est elle qui a
signé le papier pour indochine savez
quand il il avait cédé il était encore
mineure et du coup elle devait signer un
papier donc ma grand mère a refusé ce
papier et alain était très choqué dans
son coeur parce qu'il s'est dit bon ça
je peux le comprendre moi aussi j'étais
levant nourrice
il avait été levé un peu en nourrice il
essayer de rétablir le lien est
finalement au moment où il fait une
bêtise et là on pouvait justement le
faire rentrer de nouveau à
bourg-la-reine il dit ma grand mère mais
c'est pas ma grand mère qu'à signer le
papier et alain a basé toute sa vie sur
ce papier qui lui a fait bouffer c'est
alain fabien delon qui a signé ce papier
et du coup ça a fait un quiproquo énorme
qui a fait que du coup tu a adopté harry
donc il a pris ma place donc tu n'as
plus de moi ton fils ses sorties à prime
il a mis la main qu'il a pris il a pris
je prenais tout est prêt pour tous il a
toujours il faut gagner tu n'en parles
heydari dans les interviews partout des
et si vous en parlez je me lève
immédiatement il faut retenir quand même
qu'il ya beaucoup d'amour
il ya quand même beaucoup d'amour des
petites tensions qui sont normales mais
il ya beaucoup d'amour et harry
malheureusement à tueur était exclu est
ce que vient de dire isabelle c'est
juste on en a jamais parlé
vous savez j'ai beaucoup fréquenté alain
delon il n'a jamais voulu parler d'art
il même essayé deux fois jamais c'était
genre la gueule pour une semaine oui
voulait dire quelque chose dont je
trouve ça je trouve ça assez horrible
pour arrimer après on est pas on n'est
pas dans l'intimité des gens on concède
pas moi ce kit est passé par la tête
d'alain delon quand il a appris que nico
était enceinte
est-ce que voilà il eu sept enfants il
le voulait sans doute pas mon avis voilà
après il ne reconnaît pas c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment la sphère très intime
cette histoire c'est très dur pour nous
de commenter ça est-ce qu'on revend
livres harry reid a que moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'on retienne l'appel
de marie donc marie ce soir si vous
pouviez aussi voulait refaire votre
appel parce que là on dit en direct
vous êtes très inquiète pour harry très
inquiète pour harry j'aimerais que donc
j'ai écrit au juge des affaires
familiale est justement ah oui ce que
j'ai oublié de vous dire c'est que cette
femme est en train de l'épousé est clos
curateur ne peut pas interdire que moi
même je me suis pas bien qu'ils influent
oui c'est une femme qui l'inférence qui
donc qui fait plein de choses dans notre
dos et donc cette femme va le drogue la
journée quand moi je n'y suis pas et ça
c'est des suppositions non c'est pas des
suppositions s'est fondée mais le
problème c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à se
dépatouiller donc la connaissez vous
l'avais déjà rencontré cette vite fait
et vous avez d'ailleurs l'action en
justice pour essayer justement de mettre
en place quelque chose pour vérifier
qu'ils aillent bien qu'ils que cette
femme n'a pas une emprise et ses bas
c'est très difficile parce que les
hôpitaux je les fais place et ont
remarqué que des choses n'allaient pas
mais ne peuvent rien faire comme je suis
très surpris je n'ai pas voulu m'occuper
des comptes en banque d'harry j'ai une
faiblesse vaincu rate un curateur et qui
est ce monsieur me dit qu'il ne peut pas
s'opposer au mariage alors là je suis
choquée parce que personne donc là par
les juges d abraham c'est la personne
arrive donc voilà voilà
et là vous laissez entendre que cette
femme donc et se marrait la tour et du
bas elle a tout prévu
vous voulez dire que l'on n'est pas l'un
à ariha signaling elle cette femme veut
l'épouser devenir madame boulogne enfin
je sais pas c'est ton cru voir une part
d'héritage a elle aussi sûrement c'est
incroyable sûrement lina tout caméras
lors karine on voulait pas on était
vraiment cette optique là on s'ennuie
donc merci pour cette belle qui est son
père il est vrai que cette histoire est
un peu tendue aussi en tout cas d'être
venu passer cet appel j'espère qu'il va
être entendu marie soubrier au boulot
merci vous êtes tel agnès donc d'un de
longueur
[Applaudissements]